(sizzling)
- [Chef Deborah] Someone once told me
that I had three strikes against me.
I'm African-American, I'm
female, and I'm a lesbian.
In this culinary world,
we are a group of people
that are underrepresented,
and I chose to not let those
three strikes be my out.
(classical piano etude)
- [Announcer] BMW proudly
supports the LGBTQ community.
(jazz drumming)
- Twisted Soul Cookhouse is my baby.
It is a dream come true.
So what makes Twisted Soul different
from the other restaurants
in Atlanta is me.
This is my story.
So before I started
cooking professionally,
I was a flight attendant for 33 years
and I found myself on layovers.
My favorite tourist activity
was grocery shopping.
I loved working in first class
and then just adding my own little nuances
and touches to the first class meal.
At a point, I decided I
had to be true to myself
and just open a restaurant
and start cooking every day
doing something that I wanted to do.
I run Twisted Soul with my
wife and also my daughter.
We are that family that works
together and plays together.
When I first decided I
was interested in women,
I was very quiet about it.
I was afraid of how it
would affect my business.
And then I realized one day
that I was doing myself an injustice.
Once I became comfortable
with who I was and my talent,
I became unstoppable.
What I do is global comfort food,
and for me, that is soul food.
I think all cultures have a soul.
I felt like soul food was a
food that was underrepresented
and was presented as being
unhealthy, not pretty,
and I decided I wanted
to do something about it
by infusing it with other cultures.
I have a little bit of Jamaican influence;
there's Asian influence;
there's African influence.
I am telling the story of my life.
When people come to the restaurant,
I want them to experience what
it's like to be in my home.
I love to see their faces
and watch them close their eyes
and just salivate over what I've created.
Since Twisted Soul has opened,
we've been featured on major networks,
we've been featured in
multiple publications,
we get guests from all over the world,
and we're looking at opening
restaurant number two.
The soul of food for me
is what comes from within.
Being African-American,
being a female, being lesbian
in a white, male-dominated industry
has not stopped me from being myself.
Passion does not have gender,
passion does not have a color,
and my passion has taken me far.
(chiming)